okay
for people joining this meeting this is
one of
three live stream design reviews for
today means
there's a new version approaching uh
and we are talking about net function
which is a way of
injecting uh more code-like
code into um
neural nets so please
reminder let's go through the reminder i
need a reminder
no no
no what well okay hold on
that seems pretty uncontroversial to me
but
okay hold on so the idea is
and why is this not called function
layer
could be called function layer
layer is a bit abused like that
it's going to be yeah it's i mean
this is for simple stuff but it's also
more complicated things
and what does it do that isn't a layer
i mean net function oh sorry net chain
is a layer that graph is a layer
they are the same thing
i just don't want to sign up for that
much because i think net function
has the potential to be something much
bigger
i agree it is yes okay well
it isn't yet because we don't have a
good design for it yet
i'm pretty sure it should be called
function layer
wait the point is that you think and
create many layers inside it
yeah exactly it's going to be sort of a
container as well
so that's differentiators with
other regular layers that have nothing
inside them
they're always the lowest level
what is net tap please don't do that
please don't do that get rid of that
maybe it was a candidate for notify
no no no no it was everything it was for
for a cob it was a long time ago i don't
know why it's there ah
right okay sorry this was just a copy
paste of some
thing for reminder and just net tab
okay so
i don't understand this i'm sorry i
don't understand this this
is so this function
is being fed how does it know what its
parameters are
in that case there is no parameter it's
just a linear layer
what are those oh these are the inputs
of the function
yes oh i know but how does it know that
something is missing in the in the code
here
normally function as the first argument
which are the
the variables yeah but that's not right
either because this
why no no look look look look look
this is a function you don't need it you
don't need it
right you're just putting in here yeah
yeah sorry three
yeah okay so this is expecting but net
function is not telling you it's
expecting that no
function is not expecting right right
function doesn't do either so
so this is like cloud function in the
sense that it takes
a function inside it and is a thing
that then applies that function is that
right
uh yes yeah it's in the context of the
framework of course no no no no no i'm
not don't care about that that's an
implementation detail which we don't
discuss
as part of the design
we're not we have to discuss that has
three party design because it has to be
a citizen of the framework it has to
have you know he has to work together
with all the other
frameworks parts it's not an
implementation detail
okay then i would like to know the
precise specification of what you mean
by that
okay you can see that a bit a bit uh
further
so i mean i mean yes
yeah i mean it smells like a habit to me
no okay if there is one input one output
it works exactly the same as another
function so if you're good at at the
very top
with the with the example
yeah okay if it like when you put one
output you know
net function sort it works like the
function you just give the list it will
sort
yeah okay and the only question that
arises when you have multi-input
multi-output
and um and just to say that's no no no
that then
it has only one thing it can do it has
to work like function
it kind of has only one thing it can do
if it does anything different
it's a total hack
ah okay that's it that's the story now
well the thing is
okay if you want to change that you
could conceivably have a second argument
to net function
which is a preprocessor that packages
whatever it's getting in
in the form that we've had to the
function
well what you have it on the screen now
stephen i think it still works like
function
it does this one yeah
the only one that doesn't work like
functions the only one is
multi-input when the input are not named
okay and you're using hash one hash two
hash three aren't you
if you do this if you don't okay so
that's a hack and you can't do it wait
wait wait wait wait what are you talking
about
let's go to the section multi-input
so multi-input if you have named
argument this is that's fine
that's fine exactly that's fine exactly
when you have
uh the inside is a valid function that's
absolutely no problem with that
the only problem is that we cannot give
same arguments so
let's understand what you would need to
give here for this to work
this has to have some kind of currying
thing right it's
what you're transferring what is it
exactly it's splice
i think it's called splice now sequence
at that
no i don't think that's good enough
right that's not good enough
let's write out the code that it has to
use okay so so
the thing is being given a list x y z
okay now you're going to have a function
f but you want to
feed that so really what that is is just
f at
that right yeah am i making sense
so really what this is doing is this is
really equivalent to
i think
this is saying this is really apply
this is it not
yes yes
the alternative which would also work
is to say
oh my god they didn't fix this they
didn't fix this bug
the the selection bug
oh my gosh it isn't fixed
well first
okay
okay so let's go through this again so
the alternative here is you can do this
right and that needs to also work yeah
this will work no problem this is one
argument function right right
so you're trying to do the other case as
well
for convenience i think that's you know
it is nice i agree but i think that this
thing that i've given within the play
is okay one question though how can they
both
work what do you mean how can they both
work they're doing the same thing no no
i mean the
the first and the third they cannot this
one will not work
will not work it is a hack
all right
so it's don't make that hack amusingly
enough i had exactly this hack an
smp
it was a disaster how about we avoid it
i think i also run into something
similar once when i was writing a parcel
for
selection stuff yeah
[Music]
um
do you have strong opposition i mean
it's not going to happen so there's no
point in even discussing this
related things not going to happen so
now whether whether this works is a
different question
that's weird as well it seems very hacky
to me as well well i don't think it's
quite right i mean
what does this doing is function inside
so
how many posts does it have like the
nice thing it has to be two parts
well what you're trying to do is detect
how many ports it has is that correct
that that's that's one thing you want
hold on hold on i want to understand
disclosure please does this function
need to be able to deduce from its first
argument how many ports it has
can you answer the question please i
think so okay so that's going to be a
hack
right and that's the smelly hack that
you're trying to put in here
can you surface please we can also say
that
i mean okay i'm not sure you want we can
also say that there's no name
numbered argument it's only named
and we have no problem ever
no that's not right either it's still a
hack you have to go into that function
you have to go into the function it's
only going to work lexically
isn't function doing that like is of
course
it's taken with a number of slots yeah
yeah this is completely determined which
are the input of the function
the input of the function the argument
of the function are the parts
hold on let's be clear here this
function
okay ordinary function you feed it seven
arguments
it takes seven arguments the innards of
function don't work with seven arguments
it gives an error
do you understand what i'm saying we
have no mechanism
to ask function how many arguments are
you expecting
see what i'm saying not the nature of
what function does
okay so you're saying it's just a
runtime issue not when you define well
that okay but what you're trying to do
here
is to hack that you're trying to go into
the function
and find out how many arguments it's
expecting right
can you mateo can you please explain
that is that correct
i just want to clarify it i mean
i think uh jerome is writing the the
function so
jerome the is that correct or is that
not correct
that you are trying to go in and examine
the function
to determine its argument structure
correct
yes correct okay so that will not work
in general
so you understand that it will only work
lexically here if this thing has a hash
hash
that it passes to some lower function it
will fail
am i making sense yeah yeah
yeah this is not good
the double hash can work the the thing
that is difficult
is the hash uh with the with a number
after that
i see well okay but in any case this is
a hack
we surface to hack here we could remove
the
a percent and this is just like
no that will not work that will not work
because function has a mechanism right
to you know
it does not have an optimism no no i
think no it does not have a mechanism
it does not do that i mean the the the
big difference here is that function
is purely symbolic and doesn't have to
evolute anything when you define it
the obvious thing to do is there's a
second argument
which gives the signature
right so what have we done in other
cases where we have a second argument
i'm telling you this is not the right
name for this function this is we are
not ready for this function
this function at best has to be named
defensively with something
this is not the right name this isn't
the right thing
because you think it's not going to be
developed enough
to dissolve correct it's going to be too
hacky
and what's going to happen later on when
we have
essentially code that is turned into
you know neural net operations we're
going to want this kind of functionality
for code
see this is close to that but it isn't
that
am i making sense um
yeah i mean i mean
can we can we at least get rid of this
okay so here here look you've got
you've got exactly this hackery in this
case haven't you
input ports is exactly the hackery of
saying
what you know what is being fed in right
yes
i'm telling you this should be called
function layer and it should work the
same way
and eventually we will have something
that is actually called net function
that really does the right thing and i
don't know exactly how it'll work it
might have type arguments
like in the compiler or something else
okay i'm fine with the function layer
here
i'm fine with it okay well so then
let's look at if we do that
then it could potentially have
this same kind of
whoa what's happening next here
okay that it could potentially have
input ports output ports
specified like this am i making sense
so the function is simply fed
you know if
it's got if it's going to be this case
here where you know
i mean basically input ports is going to
tell it tell
outer things what shape the stuff that's
being expected in here
is do you see what i'm saying
yeah but still in many cases we can
probably get
uh without it like the the one with bob
and claire
for example i don't think you can but i
mean you can try
i think it's gonna fail most of the time
but i mean if you say input ports are
automatic
it could go and try and do a an
investigation so to speak
do you see what i'm saying yeah yeah
yeah
i mean you could also do the
investigation if you don't stay
automatic
and the the your function is wrong it is
that's its prerogative to go and check
up on you yep
i wouldn't do that actually i would just
dumbly feed the stuff in
and because because i can imagine a case
let's imagine
no no this is so broken guys come on
look the flow of the network could
involve another thing being passed in
here
but the function was just changed
because you're debugging something
and you removed one of its arguments in
other words it no longer had that
dependency
but the structure of the network still
has two wires coming in
except one of those wires the input was
ignored
do you see what i'm saying and if we
were to just change the image of the
function
and it auto magically dropped the wire
it would be very confusing
well it could just fail if the number of
input ports in the option does not match
the number of
no that's wrong that's not what you want
think about the case i just described
right change the units of the function
but you don't want to change the
structure of the network but if you
there is never um a point in which you
want to do that
if you want to change the function you
want to change a network like why
would one want to do that because by
convenience
i like it's already inside a network so
yeah
um but you know we are not even able to
represent the port that goes nowhere
yeah why not
uh i mean because it's ignored by the
function it should work
you feed in the port but it doesn't
happen to select that element of the
association
the function is independent oh yeah but
this is this is already the case i know
but i'm saying but
with your auto magic stuff it will fail
yeah
see what i'm saying it will not
correctly pick
the right keys now
this is going to be fine this input
ports thing is going to be fine if you
say automatic
which could be the default you know
it'll go and automatically try and
figure out what's going on and sometimes
it will fail
make sense
okay so now okay
i'm reluctantly agreeing to this thing
here input ports and output ports
i think we discussed that a previous
time didn't we yeah for compilation
actually the head is compliant layer
here
um there are several places where well
i'm sorry what head is compiled like
the head here is compiled layer yeah i
just copy paste from
some compared layer notebook i know but
i'm glad i'm seeing that because that's
input ports would be used in compiled
layer correct
yes and so it's also being reused in
function layer
yes i like the name function layer so
much better
it signs up for so much less
okay so let's go through now so it has
both input ports and output ports right
exactly
exactly okay so let's understand what it
does given that you've specified the
input ports
what then what happens then is that
sequence of input ports
is given as successive function
arguments to the function
correct so if i say input ports for
example let's say i say
input ports arrow i don't know what what
this is if i say
two here does that mean
that i've got a list one two or is it
what does that mean
that that means you will have two ports
with automatic naming so for example
they will be named input one and input
two
and they have unspecified shape
i don't quite understand that okay so
then then inside the function
i would be hash input one hash input two
correct
that's what i would be doing is that
correct
that is for jerome i mean we can decide
it can be one
and two input no no it cannot be one and
two because one and two
can't be done that way if you do one and
two if it's a string is it a string is
it a number
do you understand what i'm saying
so currently if you're using the
function slot
input one yeah it will create an input
prop the name input one
i'm sorry generally you're really hard
to hear
could correct he said that input one is
correct
this one here this thing here is that
right
yes okay that's okay i mean that's it's
not beautiful but it's okay
and slot one would also work but it will
take the first one
in the canonical order that's fine
because what this is being fed in
reality
is input one arrow x
input two arrow y
right and what you're saying is that
part
one of that is just x
so that's fine so oh no no no
no no no hash one will not work look at
this
hash one will not work right this is an
associate
because the only way hash one works is
if you fed the function
those var args arguments not a list
see what i'm saying
not sure no no no no no it doesn't work
that's what we just went through up here
does not work
right if it's a list it does not get its
elements from
hash one and hash two do you see what
i'm saying
yeah okay so this is the only thing that
can work in that case
unless we make a different decision
which i don't think we can make i don't
think we can do it
that allows no i mean the fact is
feeding this this case
the case hash one is not the same
as the case hash name which indexes into
an association
do you get what i'm saying yep
so okay so this case
we could unlike what is being said
we could make this actually
feed it essentially a splice
am i making sense
i don't think that directly works i
don't think you can feed a function of
splice
although it's an interesting possibility
that you may be able to do that
in other words if i have a function that
expects a list i mean it's an
interesting idea that you could feed it
splice
xyz no but is it the opposite way around
so this is a function that expects a
sequence and gets the list
and you splice the list no but the the
function expects a sequence so
just like this is this is an example of
such a function
a splice x
y b
right that function expects a sequence
there but you've given it a blob
and that blob is the splice
right
so let me think about this for a second
so let's imagine
it's an interesting idea
that a function but wait
uh how do you differentiate between i
mean the point is that splice only
evaluates inside list
that's correct and i think there's a
well in the case above you will
is it will how to evaluate before being
passed to f
or f will automatically know i'm sorry
in the case of which
you have one above f of splice x y z
right but what i'm saying is we could
extend the domain of splice
to include function argument passing
but that basically makes it like it
works with any head
which i think was no no i don't think it
does i don't think it does because this
oh i see you're saying okay the question
is
is there something you can feed into f
so that okay so is there does there
exist a function
mystery function qqq of x
y such that that is
f of x y does there exist any such
function
apply sequence
as a head each with the carried form
should even work probably
right but that's the wrong thing that
supply sequence is an old hack
well i don't think anything else exists
well
so then we maybe want to think about
this because this is the case we are
talking about here
right i mean this is a more specific
case and by the way
ets on our live stream has um
talking about uh can you disable
splicing
splicing only works inside lists which
are inert
so there shouldn't be a problem i mean
this case is probably wrong
so we're i'm retracting this case
because that could do all kinds of crazy
things
but you see this okay so
the issue is i mean this is similar to a
currying operation
right so if i say for example you know
let's let's do a headdress thing reverse
supplied
f x y right that does that
so what this is doing it's almost
like this headdress
could do this see what i'm saying
now actually that's kind of yeah but
that's already applied exactly just
apply
we have rediscovered apply right but
the point is that you want you don't
want to start from the head
yeah you your fingers starting from the
arguments
but this is not much i mean
right the question is can you have a an
argument bomb
effectively that self well
a self collection of arguments
but do do we need it just to use one
hashtag i mean
the point is uh maybe as you said uh
this is more limited in scope so the
point is that this is already very very
useful
as it is in terms of easiness of writing
complex uh
right the fact is that if all you do and
in your examples of function apply
you put an apply look let's write
function layer
right so right function layer let's just
write one
function layer of
apply f of hash one
uh plus f of hash two
okay then we're good it's just going to
work
if i'm not mistaken am i confused what's
that
no no i mean this is uh
let's look let's look i mean yeah you
can just apply to at least
oh no it doesn't work okay hold on
oh no it doesn't work it doesn't work
because
the function goes all the way inside
yes no no apply has to be outside if you
want to use it this way
right it has to be addressing for the
whole function yeah yeah right right
right right right all right so this has
to be
like this
okay so here this
will perfectly well work
that will work just fine
okay so what this is saying is if you
want to use hash one hash two
inside function layer
you've got to have an apply
in
that first argument
right otherwise just with input ports
when you specify the input ports okay
the only other possibility
is that the input ports have a
specification which causes you to have
verrog stuff be fed in
jerome you understand
yes do you understand yep
okay so let's go through it again right
so
if input ports so okay so what are the
requirements
input ports must know what the argument
structure that is being expected by that
function
is for two reasons okay has two reasons
to know that
reason number one it's external knitting
of the function layer right
correct is that correct
yes okay and reason number two
internally because it needs to know
exactly what package to feed to the
function that is the first argument is
that correct
well yeah okay so there are two
different uses
which are in fact inconsistent because
there is a case where what you want from
the input ports
is basically a list of two ports but
what you are feeding to the function
is verag's two functions right
this use case is still we we never
really even thought of that
which is the case this one that that
converts at least two to var arg
that uh the hack you were trying to pull
off that was exactly the hack you were
trying to pull off earlier
can we maybe uh i'm not i'm not super
into this input port so maybe it's even
useful
can you quickly go through what are the
possibilities that you can add to input
ports
because like this fatwa two is two ports
but then you have shapes
it was a bit where is the specification
of the ports
a bit lower
names shapes both
oh boy have we used this elsewhere
um in 12 2 that's currently being used
in
um in another layer which layers
placeholder layer where is exactly the
grammar of these input port
specifications but it's not
it's not yet there it's 12 2. i i know i
know i know i know
it should be in threading layer but we
had recently some duck problems but uh
normally threading there okay what
exactly is the gram
so you can you can do to the you can go
to the threading layer dock page and and
you will see what is currently
in released versions it's called inputs
and not input ports and it's not as
flexible as that but it's basically that
well look okay
well otherwise the way to use it is is
this either
it's an integer for just specifying a
number
or actually you can see it here inputs
number names and or shape specification
or input ports
but but wait wait wait a second no this
is 4 12 2 i think
this is this is docutools it's not the
12th
one what are you talking about yes of
course i understand that
okay so you want you want you want to
know about the new things so this is the
new thing
no no i don't want to know about look
look listen i want to know what are you
proposing for this input port
specification
okay that's it that's it okay
now what happens if you are giving
don't you also want to give data types
um so in the framework we have sort of a
it's a hacky way to to but it's there
just it should be written like names
goes to shape the last one
in the shapes you can also specify the
type okay so what we've been through
before okay and you guys are trying to
hack around it
here is
i mean this is already the case what
you're trying to do
remember the compiler has type
specifications
that don't care about the length
of its lowest level uh
lengths of arrays you do care about the
lengths of arrays
right okay so what we need to do is get
a merged specification
that works for both the compiler and for
this that allows you to elide with
automatic
the length of the array in the case of
the
did compiler see what i'm saying i get
extensive and yet again you don't have
anybody from the compiler group here
is that correct we will have people from
the compiler group in the next
compile layer meeting so maybe that's
the better place to discuss this
okay but it's going to affect okay so
listen listen coming back here
okay it's going to affect what is
actually fed to that initial function
do you understand what i'm saying yes
keep on going over the same no
right there's one thing that you should
know is that you can already specify
a shape with the name of the port
right name of the part arrow the shape
and i believe
mateo and jerome can confirm that you
can already specify
type as well so there's already a spec
that is used
in the system and it's not new it's uh
since uh 11.
yeah so where do you have an example of
something well
graph net graph documentation should be
the
most complete for this so
really what we're doing is just
extending on this we're not trying to
okay so basically it's a hack
and it's probably the right thing to do
some something i mean
you know eventually all the stuff is
going to get redone
you know this was five years ago
whenever it was more than that now
this was all intended as a preliminary
thing
because we knew that not enough was
known about neural nets
to make a final design goes to shape you
have you have this list
the table on the bottom
specifying the array shapes okay so now
what okay so you are imagining something
like that
for function layer correct yes because
it's the same exact system that
you know
what happens when in this case
in this case in in these cases the
inners of the layer
can auto magically interpret the port
specification and decide what to do
in functional layer that cannot happen
unless you have an intermediate
processing layer
do you see what i'm saying you don't
have the choice
go ahead i don't get the difference
between the function layer and net graph
for example or
or attention layer which is a layer i'll
tell you what the difference is
the difference is that in the case of
function layer you are
feeding whatever you get out from
processing the ports
raw to the function right what you've
tried to do is to hack the function
so that it can see what it's getting
from the ports and decide what to do
you can be successful at doing that if
you completely control that function
you cannot be successful in doing that
if the function is a user-supplied
function
stephen is referring to compiled layer
where you have a compiled function and
you can get a bunch of information about
it
okay among other things or attention
layer or any of these other things where
where you control what that function
does
okay right
by the way i don't know why that's a
whether that bracket is
expanded in size somebody should report
that bug
yep i got it
um by the way what do we do for
threading layer jerome because we also
have this hash
one hashtag what do you mean uh yeah
yeah we do the same
so so now actually it was extended for
12.2
that if you use a named slot in the
function that
then it will give the name of the ports
and if you use a
numbered slot then it will be input one
input two
default names
was it clear
look the only choice here
okay you have a totally hacky thing from
the sport specification
you're being bitten by that hack because
you're trying to feed these things to a
well-defined
user-defined function right so how are
we going to deal with this
so one way to deal with it is to have an
intermediate processing
step that somehow takes the hacky thing
and turns it into something well defined
am i making sense yeah yeah this a key
can become a deprecated syntax and we
can
yeah we can be closer to compile the
function compile yeah but we're not
ready for that you you're not ready for
that function completely
yeah not for 12.2 yeah of course
right so i would recommend
that what you do here
i just forget about the hash one hash
two just say hash sub one
hash sub two sorry
and if you don't want to do that wrap
and apply around it
because from the reason you don't want
to do that is because you've got another
layer of hackery going on
right which is you're actually going
into the insides of that function
and you're trying to convert it right
you're essentially trying to do
compilation
is that correct yes right
so you've got another level of hackery
so i would recommend
that you conflate the hackery and
basically say
you know you just specify for people if
you want this thing with hash one hash
to use apply
and then your compiler needs to
recognize
apply just like it recognizes a bunch of
other things
am i making sense yes
i think that's the best way to do it for
right now and then the input port
input ports have this language
unbelievably complicated language
what on earth happens when you say
varying here
what does it actually do
it's variables why is that not called
automatic anyway
because within further
it can be fixed and automatic and it
will be automatically inferred
but here you specify that it's variable
like each example can have a
different length so one of those should
probably be called inherited and the
other
could be called automatic but in any
case
that's for the future i mean that's
that's a different issue because that's
a
that's something where this is
essentially at at run time this is
variable right
that's correct yes yep whereas the other
case it's inherited
at compile time so arguably the
inherited case should be called
inherited
and this case should be called automatic
i'm not sure about that
but in any case that this yeah i mean
this is sugar but yes
um okay so now what you've got here
is a syntax yet a different syntax from
the one specified here is that correct
or not
it's extension of that to several
arguments to civil port
it's just several ports so oh i see it
you see at the beginning you have port
go to shape and this is the table for
shape this is just a list of ports
yeah it's a list of that basically i
mean yeah plus the rule version
so i don't understand this case here
i know okay so this case should surely
be an association because those ports
have to be distinctly named
um there is yeah so
we we started from
an association but then we we thought
that maybe
list of rules was a better idea because
it has to do with compiled layer and
with the fact that
arguments in the compiled function are
positional and you cannot you can never
use an association there
they're positional and so to enforce
talking about what are you talking about
it has nothing to do with that i don't
know let me explain let me explain
what the reason the reason is these the
change from association to list of rules
came from compiled layer
in which your functions don't have
only have positional arguments and so
you
this is a hack using this is the same
hack we've been talking about right
what you've got to do is the actual
function is being said
fed a processing of the things which are
being
pulled in from whatever the knitting is
with the with this layer
yeah i i i didn't want to to
make that comment a few minutes ago
because you know it
involves compiled functions which are
more complex and we don't have we don't
have anyone for okay so
hold on we don't have anybody from the
compiler team so we can't discuss it
exactly but we will in in in i know but
you're making a design here that is
supposed to cover that case
right whether another okay but results
association for that i mean
everything we care about about this now
is whether to your
association list of rules and
association is still not sorry
right so look okay
everything we're doing here okay hold on
hold on hold on
this is a giant hack tower basically in
the end
as as most of these i mean look the
choice is
you either just write code which is what
we had planned to do like seven years
ago or something
when we started this but we decided that
layers were a better idea
which i think is fine for many purposes
it is less fine you know as
i mean it's unclear to me
it's like what happened in linear
algebra where basically there are these
random
you know matrix decompositions that are
very rarely used on their own
rather people create you know use some
super function
that's a combination of these things and
the question is
and you know for example we you know
something like lu decomposition
it returns its results in a fairly hacky
form
it is the standard form for linear
algebra but it is nevertheless a fairly
hacky thing
so the question is similarly with these
things where there's the innards of
neural nets
it's not obvious i mean the fact that
lud composition returns something
which i would consider somewhat hacky
nevertheless standard in the linear
algebra community
it's never been an issue in the very
rare cases where you use the innards of
what
led composition returns you can just
unpack it and you know
and process it the way you want it why
am i talking about this
because i'm i'm i don't think this is
ultimately the way we want to do this
i think this is something you know in
the immature state
which is becoming more mature of kind of
neural nets as tools
right okay i mean i i guess i guess the
point is that
the language the wolfram language is
super expressive and
no no net function will be as expressive
as we were from language
so we need a certain point to to cut and
say okay
we stop you here and the compiler
is pretty obvious and and this one
is maybe a is maybe a bit hacky because
it's not as
clear are you sure it couldn't shouldn't
be called native function layer
or something i guess native function
layer you would expect to actually put
native code inside it
what does it do if i feature the
function what's that mature
sounds a bit uh obscure to me
it is obscure this is very obscure
because it's going to be
a voyage of discovery to figure out what
works and what doesn't
i mean we can one thing that i know is a
bit strange for our documentation but
i've always found
extremely nice is that element-wise
layer and treading layer for example
they explicitly list what they support
yes and we could refer to this list in
the
if we don't already do it actually in
the documentation of that function
say that again if you click you have a
page here you have a
threading layer for example if you click
on trading layer to open the the ref
page
you will see that trading layer also
support a subsyn
sub syntax of a language mainly
math operations and those are explicitly
listed
so if we if we can support more the list
expands
where is it listed at the top just below
the syntax box
where you have plus the the third
sentence plus subtract times time
power and this is i mean this is a bit
cumbersome but it's extremely clear to
me as a user
because i i know already when i'm
subscribing to this
no absolutely absolutely we should do
that type of thing
so the the point is like if we want to
give it a name maybe
the the functionality here is like we
take a
much bigger subset of the wall from
library than this list
and we convert it to uh
network uh primitives let's see
sorry what's the difference between
threading layer and function layer now
i mean it could be said
okay let's go back here because we're
this is a hack removal meeting
okay okay so let's understand what we're
actually trying to do here and i don't
even know what natare is and i don't
think it's gonna make it
well if there's no net array we cannot
create learnable parameters
sorry what does nat array do it
represents
an array that has parameters that can be
learned
by the okay and where is it going to be
used
innet function which doesn't exist it's
function layer
in function layer yeah in function layer
and uh how do you use it
as as a normal array so you would create
an array and then
do operation on it and uh
and that's it i'm processed with um
process heat and so on and uh and we
thought
that we could combine it with net shade
array and deprecate
shader a net charger what isn't that
shade array net
ray this thing that's allowed to share
arrays uh in a in a network
so you give a name it's a thing that i
always found a bit hacky
but it's also because sharing array in
graphs
is not something super easy in code it's
much easier
actually if you look at the weight
sharing in that function here you just
do something like that
array called net array or whatever and
then you put this array wherever you
like
and they are shared uh in in you know
so so natural array is not about
function layer right
um that will be useless from function
layer it's really
in a graph or in a chain you have to
have this stuff
that if you look at documentation no
look look i mean the fact is what you're
doing is
in a case like this where you say array
equals
that becomes a shared net array because
they're both assigned to array
if i use it separately here are a23 or
a23 they will be
unshared layers exactly exactly exactly
and this is a very natural
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
so then when it is
trained it is implicitly using the fact
that those are mutable those are
identical mutable things
that is very hacky right because if i
said
a equals b equals net a of 2 3
and then one of these i put a into and
the other i put b into you're toast
do you see what i'm saying or you you
it's very hard to know
whether you understand
if we name automatically um so that was
one of our ideas
is that every net array actually has a
name
automatically and uh so even if you do
something like that
it will still actually the worst case is
this
what on earth does that do
i mean this will uh
basically b will be a new net array
every time you use it
exactly while a it would be the first
net array that was generated
so a you could be equal to no it's much
worse than that and this this this
actual thing will be much more crazy but
that's okay
let me do it this way around then then
it will be um
but i don't think any of these are the
right thing
so what you're talking about is
a net array if you want a mutable net
array
are you expecting that the net array
will be addressable outside of your
functions
probably not do you understand what i'm
saying
in other words you could have a create
net array which produces a net array
with a uuid
and that net array with the uuid runs
around just like a symbol
addressable from anywhere so you have
array equal
create that array yeah but not in this
not inside here you can have it anywhere
that's one model for how to do this it's
just there's a mutable
array object which is like our
expression object thing
which is still not implemented i don't
think it's the right idea
so what you want to do here is
in this thing
you want to have an array that you refer
to multiple times
that is a mutable array what else is
mutable
in here i mean in other words in a in a
custom
in a layer that is of of internal design
every layer is mutable i understand
every every every layer is immutable but
what aspects of a function layer are
mutable
you're not defining that in other words
if i have a variable
in a function layer is it mutable is it
not mutable
do you understand what i'm saying yes
now what you're saying is the only
things that are mutable
in function layers are net arrays true
or not true
uh i cannot
jerome do you know if there's any other
thing mutable
sharon he
doesn't have very good connection today
sorry
but let's see let's see if it is yes but
we need a financial answer to that
question
so what what do you mean by mutable i
mean it doesn't change when you train it
that that then i guess that's the only
thing yes i mean everything that is
inside the layer and and then it's array
that's some big problems
i'm sorry i have to make problems
so yes uh i guess they are mutable and
they can be
free no no no no we're asking are the
only thing that are mutable
the net arrays yes in the function layer
are they the only things that are
mutable or not
say it again in the built-in layers like
uh
linear layers attention layers that
there can be some
something okay so there are mutable
things there yeah
okay all right
so like you you could imagine that all
the layers with parameters
that are trained you could uh write them
with that array okay with that array
exactly
but that's the wrong linear linear layer
is like a net array
dot and the plus sure
with another letter
i mean that's writing everything
explicitly in code and we're doing
halfway there and that's not going to
work
so i think the thing to do in function
layer
if there is a particular just like you
said weights arrow blah blah blah here
right what you want is in function layer
and jerome has to actually
be hearing this because otherwise he's
the one implementing it so
the in function layer
the basic point is that you have this
net array thing
which is being referred to by things in
the function
layer is that correct yes
right so in a sense now how many net
arrays could you have
in the function layer as many as you
want right
is that correct yes okay each one
effectively gets a name
for purposes and how can it be used
could i say something like a equals net
array blah blah
squared would that work
should okay
so explain to me so can i have net array
of two three equals
can it be an l value
of two three equals i don't think that
makes sense i mean it's very this is
very similar to
image yeah which is a constructor and
then it holds something once it's been
constructed yeah
you're gonna put it on the left or
something of an equal
actually no no no with the thing about
it the same way
yeah so again like image works for sure
okay so the image doesn't get updated
the issue is
that during the operation of this
function layer
the return after net train the returned
function layer is different from the
function layer that was originally given
and in particular the net array which
was abstract and symbolic
in the original untrained function layer
is now something explicit am i right
yeah i mean it will be explicit as far
as you initialize it even before
training
okay so what does an initialized net
array look like
if i say net initialize of net array
what do i get
we could principal get different uh
initialization i mean
if you say net initialize of netera do
you just get an array out
just you just get a matrix out we we
decided last time that it would be
not evaluated it would still be in an
array yeah
but the object contain the value i'm
sorry
it won't evaluate it will still be an
array but it contains the values so you
should be able to
agree okay so this isn't the correct
syntax so the correct syntax for that
array
is net array has its shape and
potentially it also has its values
now that's presumably like linear layer
has its
shape and it also potentially has its
explicit weight matrix is that correct
yes
look at constant array layer which is
something which is very close to net
array
exactly that array now and actually
yeah so for me it will be the shape and
either of the values are an
initialization method
you have it array layer the first one
the first one
we went through some iterations with the
names but yeah and probably should be
called net array layer
so and also notice just a bug that that
doesn't have its preview
yep i got it so we talked about it last
time this is just a renaming
but if we have net array you said last
time that maybe it should be called net
array layer
because it's exactly the same thing
except you have to do
open bracket close bracket to to get
some
some to be able to use it well
net array you can also you're going to
do weight sharing with array layer
because it's a layer so it's not exactly
the same thing they're very close
the sharing thing is a total hack the
sharing thing
is using is some weird total hack that
involves you going in and trying to
notice
certain patterns of variable assignment
and it's really not going to work
why i think that is it is very very neat
actually because it's a very natural way
to
to do it i know i know listen very
practical yeah listen listen
in the future we should be able to take
arbitrary code
and essentially compile it to be used
as a trainable thing with automatic
differentiation and so on
right but we are not there yet
i mean that's a side thing the question
here is how to define parameters that
will be learned
i i understand that i understand that
but the in a particular very
you know circumscribed
you know set of functions right because
function layer only supports certain
functions
in here right yeah
okay so one of the functions it supports
is assignment
for temporary variables which is its
alternative
it's essentially procedural programming
way of representing what otherwise is
done
with essentially the graph connections
of a net graph
right okay
so this
is you know really we've got
three styles of programming here we've
got
functional function applied to function
applied to function
we've got i mean what
has never happened but i have thought
about since the 1980s
and maybe have finally a way to do it
recently
is function function function functional
programming
but where those functions are not being
applied
you know f of g of h of whatever but
instead
they are being rep their their
application is being represented by a
graph
does that make sense uh
i mean the sentence makes sense in
english but i cannot visualize it okay
okay so what i mean is what i mean is
this okay we actually had prototypes of
this back in the early 1990s
but it was never useful enough
to actually implement right so imagine
we have a directed graph
so we have um
let's say oh what's a good example
this is i'm not i'm not doing a good job
here but but i mean in um
and this won't represent things properly
oops
um this is this is a bad representation
of this
okay so look this is a bad
representation sorry
what i'm saying is f of g of x
is represented by this linear graph here
am i making sense
you are mixing functions and variables
on the same plane
no no i just said
the point here is this the point here is
what you're doing with neural nets is
you're saying
and you've got port numbers here um
in
look the issue is how are you passing
arguments
right to what end up being functions
that just
eat some number of edges does that make
sense
so every function has some number of
edges coming out of it
in in order in fact which is something
not readily represented in graphs
right now do you understand what i'm
saying
yep okay so this is
and so what i'm saying is look in tensor
diagrams like in many of these kinds of
things
we could represent the composition of
functions by a graph like this
this is also something that effectively
the compiler is doing it's also
something where when you
represent a piece of code this way
register allocation becomes graph
coloring
that makes sense yeah and except that
the graph can change
on evaluation but for one evaluation you
have one trace
sort of yeah well no no but but i mean
the point is that we could write out
right now i mean the naive
way that we're writing this out is as a
tree right i mean if i
say f of g of of whatever it is h
of x and y and
uh but but but what this is not going to
capture
um
okay so if i now say expression graph
so here's the thing this is not going to
capture it's not going to capture common
sub expressions
yeah like you would with a variable
exactly right so the difference is
that in other words
were you to be able to give this
where it isn't a pure tree it's just a
dag right
the dag and this is what is done
endlessly in boolean function evaluation
and a bunch of things with boolean
functions um
i think yeah so right so the issue is
can you give can you is there a dag
way to specify what would otherwise be
an expression tree
right actually it's an interesting
general problem right so in other words
imagine an expression tree that
imagine an expression and actually it's
interesting this is an interesting
general construct
a thing that is an expression
constructor that does not use variables
but nevertheless shares things and
normally
one doesn't care so much because the
sharing of things
if the if the structure is immutable it
doesn't really matter whether it's
shared or not that's just an
implementation efficiency detail
right the difficulty you're running into
with neural nets
is it isn't immutable the thing is being
trained
and the issue is are two pieces of thing
that are being trained locked together
or not
or are they separately hanging out as
different branches of a tree
you see what i'm saying
yeah right so the reason you're getting
bitten here
is for the first time what you're
normally representing as an expression
in fact has pieces that are really
identical
because normally if i write f
of g of x g of x those two g of x's
it's an implementation detail unknown to
the user whether those g of x's
are stored in the same piece of memory
yeah
right it's true it's not for us
what's that i mean yeah no it's true
it's not yeah yeah
so okay so the issue that you have here
is
you want those two net arrays
to be tagged as being identical
right and that's why you're thinking of
this now go ahead i mean
no actually the naming things was to
solve this problem
when you have a graph so where you're
going right there
is to go back to the naming thing that
we're using in graph
but the the point in using more
procedural type
more imperative or whatever type
programming is that
it it makes this sort of thing easier at
least for our brain even though it's a
bit hacky
doesn't really fit no i i understand i i
got it i got it i got it but but the
issue is
ultimately this is going to be
represented by some expression after
you've done
all the procedural stuff here right
it's going to become some expression you
could you could evaluate that
to be an expression so long as that
expression has a way to represent
sharedness you're okay
otherwise which yeah which is good with
the naming yeah you're right
uh if you got a uid for any net layer
with uh yeah
story in that array that we create right
yeah we are good
well not quite but we're getting there
right
so then what that's doing is that's
saying
here are two things it's it's still a
little bit different because okay
let me think about this for a second i
mean if we have two symbols
right the whole point is okay two
symbols
are known to be the same right you
change them
they change together two
other expressions they only change if
their whole if their value changes but
they don't change
there's no mutable
let me think about this for a second
there's no way
well if i assign a value if i say g of x
equals whatever here then on evaluation
something will happen
see what i'm saying yeah
you have a side effect yeah but there's
something different that's going on with
on training there's no guarantee they're
the same
in other words given two things yeah you
see this this is the case you've got
f of net array seven or something
common net array seven or just for good
measure net array eight
okay are those the same net array or not
are they being trained
locked together or not well in this case
you i mean if you call a constructor
twice
i would imagine as a user that this is
creating two different things
yeah but i understand that but that's
but my point is
that your way of doing that by using
the fact that you know you're using a
piece of
meta information that is not guarantee
that's the difference between equals and
colon equals
right you're using the fact that an
equals
no it's just wrong it's just wrong look
the semantics of equals is
you take the value at the time of the
assignment
and you put it in a for example that
doesn't mean
you take a value that is subsequently
mutable and put it in a
that's the wrong thing
that's an abuse but the value of the
value of an array
is an object which is itself mutable is
not
an array i understand that but but
the whole point is when you say a equals
net array
b equals a
normally the semantics are b gets the
current value of a
but what you're saying is well actually
it's not a current value it's this
weird thing that can be changed later
and that's
different from what normally is the
semantics of assignment
like with entities if i say like a
a equal dog and then b equal a and then
i change i mean
properties are gotten from the server so
that's not different than training
then you when you ask the the dog race
then you query for it
and it can change later what you have
assigned to a and b are
just
i give you credit for that being an
interesting example
yeah i mean the semantics of
of entities that change their values
while you're doing a computation
is an interesting one i mean forced upon
us by the world
yeah but very complicated
like how often do you refresh it in the
inner loop
where you're using you know the weight
of a dog which apparently might have
been changed by the
you know international dog breeders
association or something
you know at the moment inside your code
running
when is it cached when is it not that's
a really complicated but this is but
this is actually an interesting point
because if i'm
programming with entities what i would
do is i would
query the property at the beginning and
then just
use the property as a value exactly not
the entity as an object
and here the similarity is like if i i
don't extract the array from the net
array i keep it in that array with the
name
neterrade dog and that array dog is the
same literary dog everywhere
and it when i use it i query its value
at runtime similar to what if i don't
pre-evaluate the entity property
yeah but okay so let's come back to this
okay so the issue here is so we've got
two levels of
issue okay one is the incoming shape
which i think we've more or less handled
with this input ports thing but i think
it has to be thought through carefully
knowing that we have no control once it
is fed to the user function it must be
in the standard form for a user function
make sense nobody agree
yeah right it can't it can't have
anything where it goes into the user
function
and says aha i can accept a different
form
okay then the second question is
how do we have trainable arrays in the
user function
right in other words okay what data
in the user function is trainable
okay anything inside a layer
in the user function is trainable
insofar as that layer is trainable
correct
yes okay so
the difference with that array is this
sharing business
because a layer if i'm not mistaken if i
say well this is another question if i
say a equals b equals linear layer
yeah they are two different linear
layers if you train a you don't train b
what what what what what what what what
what what what what
are you saying if i say down here
i think we would i mean
if you create a collinear layer and you
do a
i don't know a chain of this two linear
layer with spring with a
so my question is
um my question is in that case
are you telling me that that's different
from that array
from a equals b equals net array it
should probably be the same
well i think both are semantically
troubled
okay so let's go through this again okay
i think you have to decide whether i i
think the unnamed
but connected thing is just not going to
work
i mean we can name everything that that
was our look actually crazy idea the
third thing
i saw that's exactly right about that
let's think about it because
because when you say
what you're saying is that the
true form of net array is net array
shape comma id
and if you enter a net array without its
id
then it will be given an id and then
subsequently
whenever you have this net array when
you use it
it will be a net array with an id
right so in other words if i say a
equals net array of shape
what will actually be assigned to a
because of the semantics of immediate
assignment
is a net array of shape comma id
yeah so then your stuff
where you say b equals a it's a happy
thing
it'll just work exactly okay
so let's let's go through again what
this means so then
okay so if i want to generate
two yeah i think this will work
i think this will work i'm a little bit
concerned about it
um
is the only concern i have is the naming
which naming like how do you create the
uid by default
and uh well when just one of the one
argument form
is a is a fragile object which just
uuids itself
in the two argument form or whatever
maybe yeah it's your idea but you know
you
could have you know in two sessions you
create two things that happen
to have the same uid and then you load
them together and then you just no it
can't happen
it's a axiom of the universe that uuids
never collide okay
but yeah it's probably very rare no no
no no it's an axiom that uuids will
never collide
because in other words that it is i mean
amusingly
amusingly in our actual physics model
effectively you have to say that
there is this notion of identity and it
is axiomatic
that no two sort of independently
created atoms of space can be the same
they can be isomorphic but they can't be
the same
um and amusing but but um
uh and and i think for practical
purposes the whole point of the uuid is
it's long enough
that it won't collide yeah right so you
just
it's just taken for granted so that
means that every
net array in every different session is
different
the the so do you do you want a b equal
linear layer to use a crazy idea
linear layer should we at least
investigate it like is linear layer
evaluating its net arrays inside
so it is fixed id or not
i mean what have we done previously with
linear layer i mean
it's independent that they're
independent
yes i think that that
should continue to be the default unless
unless for some
i i don't think you can change that i
mean i think you should think through
that default
but i think you can't change that for
what we've done so far
now okay jerome didn't you say that
tally thought that it was a mistake that
we should have made them
oh jerome is gone okay i think jerome
told me two hours ago
kelly was saying it was a mistake that
that we should have made them
be the same layer
uh in the case of a equals b equals
another layer yeah
the point is well why don't you
investigate whether it's possible to do
that with these ids
i don't think it should be an argument i
suspect it should be an option somewhere
okay and and one thing you can do much
like we do for cryptography
is represent the the um uh
you know if i say encrypt you know
foo
brilliant
okay see you've got things like that
which are i mean that's a rather big one
but you understand that's a way of
representing
that colored weird thing the main point
is if i say
um if i encrypt something else
right i don't know what it is but that
is a representation of the encrypted
bits
did you see what i'm saying
and that's the same thing you could do
in the
in um uh something like that
is something you could do with these
with the display form of these id'd
linear layers because you definitely
don't want to see
uuid blah blah blah blah blah but you do
want to see are these the same or not
so you much know it glass if they are
the same
yeah yep what time setting
this is a type setting yes it's just a
clever way to do that
yeah i guess we should investigate what
are the
the the tendrils obvious i mean like if
will it break everything will it break a
havoc in the framework if we change this
thing well i know i know i know you need
to look at that
i mean i don't think it will affect
anything that already exists because you
don't have assignments right now
people well in construction notebooks
exactly
exactly i don't know what can be done i
don't know you should look at it but
but then the the other thing is this
sharing this business which i think we
should talk about in a separate meeting
this business about the representation
of shared sub expressions
in case like this which i think you're
going to need
right this is a way around that by using
ids
but in the end this is going to be
something desirable
make sense all right i just want to
comment on some things on our live
stream and then we need to i need to go
um oh lots and lots of things
here uh i see
i still have to figure out how to
pronounce this i'm going to call it ic
because i don't know how to pronounce it
um i'm probably just being stupid it
probably spells something clever but i
don't see it okay so
ic was commenting about a guide for
designing functions
unfortunately we have
a few such things but it's a difficult
business
i mean i've spent like 40 years learning
this stuff
um i'm not sure you know there are some
principles which we have enunciated
and i don't know where we have we used
to have a design analysis group
which is uh since disbanded because
basically
different individual development groups
all
learnt how to do their own design
analysis used to have some list of these
things i wonder where it is we should
try to find it
um yeah we should try to find this devin
that would be an interesting thing to
try to find i don't know whether it's
out there on the web
but it is interesting it's pretty
obvious i mean it has a lot of obvious
principles
um okay
next thing here
um comment from sander
about functions
that this case here
function
yes it ignores subsequent arguments in
other words
it is
i remember thinking about this at great
length 33 years ago or something
um and
yes i mean this was somewhat informed by
what happens in lambda calculus
uh yeah
it is what it is not changeable anymore
um
okay let's see
splice uh nick says splice should have a
second argument for a head that it
is allowed into splice into yes i firmly
and completely agree
and let's put that back on an ild agenda
the last time
i raised that it i tried very hard to
shoot it down but i think it needs to
uh ride again
it's a good idea actually a pattern for
what to spice into
um ethan is commenting bigger issues
that net function is limited
yes yes we know that um
steve is saying import from tensorflow
yeah and that's a whole complicated
story
of uh you know of of changing
standards for what this and that is and
what we're right now concentrating on is
onyx
uh which should allow us to be
uh portable across many different
frameworks
um
yeah nick is commenting dynamic graph
construction yes we're aware
um
yes well this is um uh
nick is commenting that array with with
tensor algebra and surgery operations
and auto differentiation yes we're aware
and i mean the same issue
about tensor diagrams
oh boy yeah i mean it's coming up in a
lot of different places
it's coming up in our discussion about
um
um all of these
uh array reduction kinds of things it's
also coming up in our
zx calculus stuff for the physics
project
yes it is it is it is a something it is
having its moment here
uh ethan is saying why not net variable
yeah right push is saying
why is it net array why is it not
something which
is a why isn't that a more general
construct
okay the ethernet is talking about a
graph of neural nets well in a sense
a graph that's what net graph does
transformer nets ethan per comments are
just graph nets
so i don't know what what is a graph net
what does that mean as opposed to a
does it mean a net that operates on
graphs
anybody want to comment on that
nothing precise but i know there's a lot
of
thinking about what transformer really
is and trying to change the paradigm
of how we should view neural networks to
be
something where they're operating not on
arrays but on graphs
yeah including i mean the problem is
it's going to be the same story as it's
been from the beginning of this whole
business
which is the more general the less
trainable
i mean that's been the you know that's
been
although that story is beginning to
decay
as you know more automatic
differentiation
becomes possible but that was for a long
time that was kind of the generic story
um
trying to make propagation networks
computation graphs with pointers
asynchronous calls information
propagation
that's interesting okay i don't know
what that is
anybody know what propagation networks
are
that oh i see
i see yeah okay so this is like a
generalization
of the concept of spreadsheets where
there's
i mean there's one thing where it's
where it's immediate evaluation it's
just
a graph that represents a function
look i mean gosh this problem
of graphs that represent functions you
know i'm embarrassed to say that i have
been grappling with this problem since
the late 1970s and i think it's time to
actually solve it
that is the duality between
the passing of um
uh you know passing values around and
the propagation
of information through graphs and i
think
that the physics project story which
reveals how complicated that is with
you know where things can be passed in
parallel and so on
um probably time to really solve that
it's guaranteed to be heavy lifting in
terms of design and it's also
if done correctly it will provide an
actual
uh framework for doing parallel
programming
that with luck might be understandable
to humans
i mean as opposed to what we're doing
right now which is
you know our quotes parallel programming
is mostly array programming
which is understandable you take the
whole array you do something to it
what we're doing as we do all this array
reduction stuff is a
is a you know is the first you know the
generalization of that
is arbitrary parallel weird stuff going
on
that isn't just slicing arrays along
axes and knitting them together and so
on
anyway interesting stuff alright
um
uh okay
um sounds good
oh it's some
steve is asking something about a ray of
region of sphere spheres and balls are
not the same thing a ball is a filled in
sphere a sphere is just the surface
um okay
all right anything else here
i think we're good okay thanks very much
thanks everybody on the live stream in
another
hour and a bit we will be continuing
with a live stream about calculus and
algebra features for 12.2
um all right see y'all later